what's up GQ I'm Pusha T and these are
my essentials all right so item number
one on my air pods they just make
traveling convenient for music as well
as me charging my phone at the same time
while I'm still communicating with you
I'm an apple guy 100% nothing else
exists like I don't want to see green on
my text chains anything no when I first
was introduced to him it was giving me
Bluetooth vibes and that's like a washed
characteristic of life you know somebody
who's not in touching in tune but these
are pretty cool this is the key to life
morning and night I wash my face with
this this right here is my Aveeno clear
complexion foaming cleanser okay I buy
this in every city that I go to because
TSA throws out this very very big bottle
every time they go through my bag I
don't care I'm still gonna buy it I'm
still gonna try to get through TSA with
this sometimes my TSA agents are cooling
it like which we know you're not gonna
try to blow up a plane you got it go
through other times they're jerks and
they throw it and then slam dunk it and
they look at me and they say hey you
knew this was too big why did you even
try me
this is just something that I live by I
have friends they go to like these
dermatologists and all this stuff no you
can go to CVS and get greatness okay
right here we have the kills age
defender facial moisturizer people say
that you know I look pretty young for my
age you know you know I used to like
blame it on being from Virginia and just
you know having like a stress-free life
but today this right here this is what's
helping me kill this killer you know on
this scrap the crack that removes cracks
my next essential Uniqlo t-shirts I live
and die by these things they can always
make you look like you're dressed for
whatever the occasion is it's dressed
down but it has a little Lux to the T
something Lux about it a little bit and
I need a sponsorship like I need to be
sponsored it's something that I buy
every time I hit New York City I rip the
bag open i steam it and put it on this
is my Louboutin watch case it holds
three watches one of which is always on
my wrist these three watches are the
watches that I travel with all the time
she's all-purpose I have a pretty big
collection of Rolexes but these are the
three that I just go to cinema Toledo
Rolex meant I meant a lot coming up it
wasn't a point of achievement but for me
and guys like me in the street and just
trying to you know get big money up and
and this was like man we made it this
was a benchmark like ah we got that
platinum rose gold go
also my travel essentials on my cardio
bracelets these are gold white gold rose
gold they're a headache to take off
because you have to unscrew them with
like a screwdriver so I just keep them
long all day every day I work out and
then they say the more scratches that
you get it gives them character I'll go
for that it's you know it's easy it's
easy to think of it that way
every scratch is a story I don't know
the story I've been telling you I
believe I was lifting weights I was
moving something around the house who
knows the essentials here are my grills
I get so many pairs of these made as you
can see this is my top layer of teeth
this is actually my mold it's my top
teeth and I got grills for two corners
this is the bottom bridge she's a these
are white coal more white gold corners
my cooling down these are my staggered
grills when you put them in it's like
you know golden diamonds then it skips a
tooth and then it might be a window and
then you know it just gives like
attitude this is my gold wallet it's
pretty dirty
it's pretty beat-up has a lot of
character but if I do not have this
wallet with this thickness I will not
know that I even have a wallet on me red
just popped at the time it's dirty now
but I don't care I think it says a lot
about probably how long I've had it the
thing that I use the most
this right here this is fine these are
my lucky numbers I carry my lucky
numbers in my wallet and these my lucky
numbers for the game roulette
I never ever ever ever ever ever
don't take this with me when I go gamble
go your wallet definitely and essential
I don't but I do have my gun license and
this is definitely in essential so the
next essential I have I'm actually
wearing and it's st. Laurent
it's black denim I probably have
purchased 90 pair of these sometimes you
just you need that new feeling over
having on new jeans creature of habit
man like for real I don't I don't want
to change much and I feel like it's
classic you can never go wrong with
classic all this stuff I always have
with me I gotta put it somewhere so my
Rimowa carrying case has been the most
trusty I don't worry about it I can
carry it on the plane or I can't be
checking in and I don't worry about it
being banged up scratch scraped whatever
even if it does it's harmless you know
it's just practical super mobile easy
and convenient man anything that I need
right here right now ripped it open done
deal
hi guys thanks for checking out my stuff
maybe you'll catch me at the airport
fighting with the TSA